messieur et bien ce soir à musicque and
musique nous allons nous promener dans
l'œuvre poétique d'un compositeur
important d'un poète authentique et et
d'un ami et d'un ami ce qui est bien
agréable et à l'énoncer de son nom tout
ce que la chanson française compte de
formidable a répondu présent alors ce
soir avec la l'avantgarde de la chanson
française autour de lui avec vous avec
nous nous accueillons Serge ginsbourg
avec une chanson de ces début le
poinonneur des Lilas Serge
[Musique]
ginbau le gars qu'on croise et qu'on ne
regarde pas il y a pas de soleil sous la
terre trôle de croisière
pour tuer l'ennui j'ai dans ma veste les
extraits du R Gest et dans ce bouquin il
y a
écrit que dégass la coule douce à
Miami pendant ce temps que je fais le
soive au fond de la cave par qu'il y a
pas de son métier moi je fais des trous
dans des billets je fais des trous des
petits trous encore des petits trous des
petits trous des petits trous toujours
des petits trous des trous de second
classe des trous toute première
classe je fais des trous des petits
trous encore des petits trous des petits
trous des petits trous toujours des
petits trous les petits trous les petits
trous les petits trous les petits
trous je suis le coinonneur des Lila
pour invalide changé à
Opéra je vis au cœur de la planète j'ai
dans la tête un carnaval confti j'en
amène jusque dans mon lit et sous mon
mon ciel de faillance je ne vois briller
que les
correspondances parfois je rêve je dis
vague je vois les vagues et dans la
brume au bout du piier je vois un bateau
qui va me chercher pour me sortir de ce
trou je fais des trous des petits trous
des petits trous toujours des petits
trous mais le bateau se taille et je
vois que je
déroille et je reste dans mon trou à
faire des petits trous des petits trous
des petits trous toujours des petits
trous des petits trous des petits trous
des petits trous des petits
trous je suis le poin sonneur des ldin
AR et métier direct par le valoin j'en
ai marre j'en ai ma claque de ce cloque
je voudrais jouer la fille de l'air
laisser ma casquette au vestiè un jour
viendra j'en suis sûr où je pourrais
m'évader dans la nature je par sur la
grande route et cooute que coûte et si
pour moi il est plus TS je partirai les
pieds de vant je faerai des trous des
petits trous encore des petits trous des
petits trous des petits trous toujours
des petits trous il y a de quoi de venir
dingue de quoi prendre un
fling se faire un trou un petit trou un
dernier petit trou un petit trou un
petit trou un dernier petit trou et on
me mettra dans un grand trou et
j'entrendrai pu par les trous puama trou
de petit trou de petit trou petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trou Serge ginsbourg qui donne obstant
une entorse et ça arrive a tenu ce soir
à assurer ce musique à musique et je
l'en remercie ça